i'm half white half filipino oh your
dad's white yeah
and uh so yeah that's that that's that's
the cosmetic makeup of uh the herbert
family
slash coy herbert okay who's coy
coy is my nickname for my aunt my aunt
called me jokoy but i went up as herbert
when i started in 89
i used to go it's my name i used to grow
up as joseph herbert
and people would laugh you know what i
mean you do open mics the
the you know the emcee whoever the
[ __ ] mc would be like make fun of the
name you know what i mean like
if i said my name or people would heckle
my name so it was always me with the
struggle with my name
and then uh not realizing i had a cool
nickname which is my aunt ati evelyn she
would always call me jokoy but she would
say like chocolate with an accent
so you don't think of a nickname that
would be good for stage
until i was like looking for a different
name and that's when it hit you and then
that's when it hit me when i was at her
house and she goes to ahoy eat and i go
that's my name
i'm going to go as joe coy and then
that's how that all started
yeah i'm glad i'm glad it happened
um because i didn't know it was gonna be
that catchy it was like it was a catchy
name but i literally was doing it
because i was getting tired of people
[ __ ] up my name or making fun of the
name and just stupid
so your mom but i think herbert is cool
yeah yeah
right mm-hmm that's why he's so funny
about it you [ __ ] like i have pt
i have ptsd because of it i literally
have ptsd
like i literally like my last special i
finally talked about it
you know i mean i was just like herbert
and then i swear to god when i said it
someone laughed i go
that's why i [ __ ] changed my name was
it justin
comedy or your whole life no no growing
up in school i didn't think any of that
everyone
loved it everyone used to call me herb
you know what i mean i used to go by
herbert i loved it it was right when i
started comedy
like that you'd be like a bear it's
comedy
especially like the upping you know like
you're doing open mics they're just
trying to find some
i get it but [ __ ] it was like ptsd dude
i used to hate going to new open mics
like what's your name like joe joseph
herbert like what
what is that german like no bro just
[ __ ] say my name
just say my name it was like annoying
and then
yeah so that's what that was all about
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you